welcome back y'all to the end of my
surprise 40th birthday show
i'm sad at thinking
but it was a really great time i love it
so much it's gonna take me at least an
hour to finish off the rest of that
queso fountain alone in my dressing room
please
um okay maybe 45 minutes um which
reminds me it's time for what i'm liking
[Music]
all right so we've got tampa bay's mlr
tv on air personality jason guy on the
line who's gonna guide me along so jason
great to meet you
so where are you great to meet you kelly
sending you happy birthday wishes from
the eighth annual pier 60 sugar sand
festival uh you might be jealous here
i'm in sunny clearwater beach florida
yes this is a huge festival it brings in
200 000 people over 17 days people enjoy
walking on that pier just think about
that stroll you can ride a ferris wheel
here or even relax on the beach but the
real star is sugar sand clearwater's
most famous natural asset and
kelly you've got to see this it looks
and feels just like real sugar ah it's
amazing here and sand sculptors come
from all around the world to create
amazing works of art out of sand so this
year we're taking the sand and animals
and creating a theme of sandomals do you
like that so i'm here in this ted it's
21 000 square feet of uh sculptures
there are 150 of them in here everything
from an aardvark to a zebra in here and
i've got some cool dolphins behind me
look at this giant dolphin and some
other marine animals and it all pays
tribute to the clearwater marine
aquarium i love oh i love an aquarium
i'm a huge fan so tell me about that
aquarium
okay so the clearwater marine aquarium
is a great place that not only takes in
these sick and injured animals but they
work to rehabilitate them and hopefully
release them so it's really great the
aquarium gets this tribute it's a great
way to honor all of the good and amazing
work that they're doing here now there
is one thing
that's happening at this festival okay
there is a sandomal sculpture that
hasn't been revealed to the public yet
it is a kelly clarkson show
exclusive are you ready for this for
your birthday
happy birthday
we've got henry
and of course henry's best friend
you included my dog that's so nice oh my
gosh i love you i know
this guy and all florida say happy
birthday kelly well thank you so much oh
my gosh it was so nice thank you to
jason god tampa bay's mlr tv and the
pier 60 sugar sand festival on
clearwater beach which i was there right
now i'm liking that post right now and
that's not all our season long partner
pilots and makers of friction to go to a
raceful pin of the kelly clarkson show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly which is exactly what the
pier 60 sugar sand festival is all about
so they're writing a check to the sun
sets at pier 60 society for a thousand
dollars
[Music]
you